Speaker 1: Let's go next to Tristan from Oregon.
Tristan, welcome to the program.
Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
It's been a long time since I've called your
show.
I'm the blind guy who called your show a couple
of years ago during the height of the pandemic.
I was dealing with some backlog grocery issues
at the time.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Great to hear from you again.
Speaker 3: Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
So two questions.
One's much more relevant than the other.
I know on one of your recent streamed, you,
you said that you were a fan of chocolate
babka.
I just got recently introduced to the world
of chocolate vodka via Trader Joe's.
And I just wanted to get your opinion, like,
is that Trader Joe's chocolate bar code any
good?
Speaker 1: I have no idea.
I've never had it.
You know, I do think that I don't know what
the situation necessarily is where you are
as far as Bobcat goes.
But if you could find like a Jewish deli that
has babka, I might go there before I go to
Trader Joe's.
But maybe the Trader Joe's chocolate babka
is fine.
Speaker 3: I mean, I've already tried.
It is excellent of the highest order, I must
say.
So I imagine, I imagine the Jewish deli would
be other worldly and maybe so.
Speaker 1: Maybe so.
Yeah.
Listen, it's.
It's good.
It's good if you can find it at all.
I think that's a good start.
Speaker 3: Yeah, definitely.
Definitely.
But I know my next question, just given all
of the sort of atmosphere that we have in
this country and Trump's announcement on Tuesday.
Yep.
Just with everything going on and this is
very sort of a philosophical, esoteric question.
Speaker 1: My favorite type of question.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
How much time do you think we thought American
democracy, just in terms of the election and
Trump's announcement?
Speaker 1: You're saying with his announcement,
how much time we bought?
Speaker 3: Well, just the totality of it,
the election and his announcement and just
the general political sort of atmosphere.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I don't.
For me, it's so the results of the midterms
to some degree are reassuring, although Republicans
are still taking the House and they almost
took the Senate, but they didn't.
And, you know, it's going to be two years
of gridlock, but to some degree, at least
enough people cared about the outcome to hold
off an actual red wave.
On the other hand, with Trump's announcement,
Trump's announcement itself was pretty dystopian.
But what I'm a little bit reassured by is
how boring everybody in the room found it
and how in all the polling that's recent,
Trump seems to be losing in most of the polls
to de Santos, who hasn't even announced his
candidacy.
So I have like a small, cautious optimism
that the Republican Party is ready to be done
with Trump.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I'm hopeful.
I had actually turn away from his announcement
because I just I was falling asleep and it
was amazing.
Speaker 1: It was incredible.
It was a lot of the same stuff he's been doing
at the rallies, but presented in a more boring
monotone combined with I'm running for president.
It was very strange.
Very, very strange.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I'm not I'm not quite sure.
Yeah.
Do you think that, like, if Trump loses in
the primaries to disband his or somebody else,
do you think he's going to keep claiming fraud
or do you think he's going to pivot somehow?
Speaker 1: I hope that he runs as an independent
if that happens, just because it would be
so terrible for the Republican Party.
I don't I'm not, you know, kind of holding
my breath.
But it would be amazing for for Trump to just
run as an independent, take like 15% of the
Republican vote and prevent the Republican
nominee from winning.
That would be great.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
You definitely have a point there.
I hope he does, too.
Well, that's all I had interested.
You just remind.
Speaker 1: Me of your blindness.
Tell me about it.
Ah, I just don't remember.
Are you completely blind?
Speaker 3: I am completely blind.
In both eyes.
Have been since I was born.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So you.
This is if I know that this is not new ground,
but like, if I say to you that, like, the
background of my set is blue, does that have
any meaning to you?
Oh.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
I mean, like so just throughout my lifetime,
I've just kind of been able to contextualize
what colors are.
I remember, like asking my dad, what is black?
Like, what is red like?
And, you know, red is like the bright, you
know, sort of, you know, I remember being
on, you know, describing it while I was engaged
in some substances.
Like, man, it's like it's like you're it's
loud to the eyes and, you know, blue is kind
of like it's softer, but it has a bright color.
It's it's hard.
Interesting.
And they have some meaning to me.
But it can it can be a little tricky.
But and and yeah.
Speaker 1: And so you have no idea what I
look like, right?
Speaker 3: Not really, no.
I mean, you've described yourself a little
bit, but I don't have any idea what you look
like now.
Speaker 1: Interesting.
Very, very interesting.
Wow.
Well, trust and listen, I appreciate you calling
in.
And we're going to keep an eye.
It sounds like you and I are keeping an eye
on a lot of the same thing, so I appreciate
it.
Speaker 3: All right.
Thanks so much, David.
You take care.
Speaker 1: Due to there is Tristan from Oregon.
Great to hear from him.
Let's go.
Why don't we go next?
I mean, why not?
Right.
Let's go to Bryce from Scotland.
Bryce, welcome.
Speaker 3: Home.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: You sound like you're completely
underwater.
Your audio is totally muddled.
Speaker 3: Okay.
I will do my best to try.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's a little better.
Speaker 3: It's all.
Speaker 1: Oh, God.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: Right.
Uh, no.
Boy.
Second.
Speaker 1: Well, what was your question, Bryce?
Let's see if we can understand each other.
Speaker 3: Night.
I'll do.
I'll do my best.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to be too pessimistic, but.
Do you think there's a way at all?
Obviously, you've probably seen the Duke.
The Duke politics is up to the moment with
three prime ministers in seven mix.
Speaker 1: Sorry.
What's happened in seven weeks?
Speaker 3: Price.
So so let me and.
Speaker 1: I'm going to let you go for now
just because the audio is it's not maybe it's
me.
I might be having an issue, but I'm going
to let you go for now.
And let's see if we can.
Let's see if we can reset.
Let's try.
Oh, I don't know.
How about Nate from Rhode Island?
What's going on, Nate?
Speaker 3: Hey, David.
How you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 3: Satisfaction for you is not as
mainstream, but it's about the Second Amendment.
China, the first sentence of the Second Amendment,
states about a regulation, a well-regulated
militia.
Does that mean we can regulate them to the
point of, like, Japan, for instance, like
and not to say that I doubt this current court,
which is shake it down.
But what do you think about that?
Speaker 1: No.
So a lot of those semantics, Second Amendment
arguments have all kind of been explored and
and they're just kind of retreads.
So I don't know the answer to that there.
It's not where I would be focusing my activism
on gun safety regulation.
I would be focusing on let's do the things
we know we can do that don't depend on the
linguistic nuances of how it's written and
instead say, like, we got to eliminate the
possibility of any gun sales without a background
check.
We've got to limit high capacity magazines.
You know, we have this full list.
I would focus there instead of on these linguistic
concerns.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Well, thank you.
I just had that fight in my head for a little
while and I to get that out.
Thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it very much.
Let's take a very quick break.
We're going right back to the phone.
So if you're holding on to talk to me, don't
hang up.
And we'll get back in just
a minute.
Let's go back to discord and talk to a few
more people.
David Pakman dot com slash discord is the
place to find it.
Why don't we go next to Thomas from Denmark?
Thomas, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Thank you, David.
Just a quick question about gun laws and how
Republican a Republican state they view it,
types like Ted Cruz.
What will you what do you think it will take
to to change the way the.
They look on condors.
How?
Sorry.
It doesn't fit.
Thomas.
Speaker 1: Oh, and Tom Thomas is gone.
Speaker 3: Oh, boy.
Speaker 1: All right,